hi I'm Vanessa Redman I work with first
offense legal a and right now we are in
Chicago Illinois so when you are stopped
by the police you have some basic rights
some of them they read to you with the
Miranda rights sometimes they don't read
the memories right now these rights you
have whether you stop for a reason or
whether you stop for no reason you do
not have to consent to a search you tell
the police if they exit search you
I do not consent to a search sometimes
they won't act so we'll just start
searching you that's when you say I do
not consent to a search if you don't say
anything then you're illegally you're
giving them your consent so you have to
verbally say those words you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
will be used against you and that's why
you should not talk to the police about
anything without a lawyer present so on
the police ask you questions you say I
will not talk I want my lawyer and you
wait for your lawyer to get there you
want to know if you're being arrested
you were asked am I free to go because
the police can lie to you and say no I'm
not just handing you know you're not
being arrested but yet they're not
letting you go so there's
straightforward ways to find out if
you're being detained or arrested as am
I free to go if they say yes then you
calmly walk away if they say no then
understand that you are being detained
and you remain calm and continue to
invoke your rights